One of the things that made marks wrong
was Marx believed that capital would
flow into the hands of fewer and fewer
people and that the association between
the rich and the poor would become more
extreme as capitalism developed and like
so many things that mark said.
That's it's kind of true.
It's kind of true in that
the distribution of wealth and in fact
the distribution of anything that's
produced follows a peritoneal pattern
and the prieto pattern basically is that
a small proportion of people end up with
a bulk of the goods and it isn't just
money.
It's,
it's anything that people produce,
creatively ends up in that distribution
and that's actually the economists
called out the matthew principle and
they take that from US statement in the
New Testament and the statement is to
those who have everything more will be
given and from those who have nothing.
Everything will be taken and it's a map
of the manner in which the world
manifests itself.
Where human creative production is
involved in the map seems to indicate
that as you start to produce and you're
successful,
the probability that you will continue
to be successful or accelerate increases
as you're successful and as you fail,
the probability that you will fail
starts to accelerate.
So in your progress through life looks
like this or like this,
something like that.
And the reason that Marx was right was
because he noted that as a feature of
the capitalist system.
The reason that he was wrong is that
it's not a feature that's specific to a
capitalist system.
It's a feature that's general to all
systems of creative production that are
known and so it's like a natural law and
it's enough of a natural law by the ways
that the distribution of wealth can be
modeled by physical models using the
same equations that govern the
distribution of gas molecules in a
vacuum.
So it's a really profound.
It's a fundamentally profound
observation about the world way the
world lays itself out and it's
problematic because if resources accrue
unfairly to a small minority of people
and there's a natural law like element
to that that has to be dealt with from a
social perspective because if the
inequality becomes too extreme,
then the whole system will destabilize
and so you can have an intelligent
discussion about how to mitigate the
effects of the transfer of creative
production into the hands of a small
number of people.
Now,
the other reason,
however,
having said that,
the other reason that Marx was wrong,
there's a number of them.
One is that even though
creative products end up in the hands of
a small number of people,
it's not the same people consistently
across time.
It's the same of people and that's not
the same thing.
You know,
like imagine that there's water going
down a drain and you say,
well,
look at the spiral.
It's permanent.
You think,
well,
the spirals permanent,
but the water molecules aren't.
They're moving through it and it's the
same in some sense with the prieto
distribution is that there's a one
percent and there's always a one
percent,
but it's not the same people.
It's the stability of a diy differs from
culture to culture,
but there's a lot of movement in the
upper one percent,
a tremendous amount of movement,
and one of the reasons for that movement
is that things get large and then they
get too large and then they collapse,
and so in 2008,
when the politicians said too big to
fail,
they got something truly backwards as
far as I can tell,
and that was.
It was a reverse.
The statement was reversed.
It should have been so big it had to
fail.